everybody wants to know about the beard
but nobody questions the cookies on
nobody has ever asked me is the cookie
zone real one glance they're like yeah
he's for sure a fat guy but I wonder if
he's faking the facial fur hi my name is
Santa Tom getting's I'm a real bearded
Santa Santa Ricker wouldn't here with
the Fraternal Order of real bearded
Santa's today we're here to answer some
questions for you all so without any
further ado let's see who's first do you
keep a nutty nice list for people in
your day to day life
well yeah people who know me know better
than to be naughty anywhere any time I'm
around so I do in my head that in my
heart what do you do when a child
accuses you of not being the real Santa
Oh every sin that deals with this
different but I'll say something like
[Music]
that's how all right you just try to
explain to them that Santa the real
Santa is more in their heart than
anything and we're here to help them to
help Santa out to find out who's being
naughty and nice and we just try to give
them the answers to make them wonder
whether we could be real or fake what is
your favorite kind of cookie now you're
gonna hear from almost everybody that
this changes from time to time and for
Santa it's just as true my favorite this
year is white chocolate chip macadamia
but I'd have to say if there was an
all-time average my lifetime favorite is
still meal raisin chocolate chip second
favorite would be sugar cookie there's
nothing like a good warm chocolate chip
cookie waiting for me at night do kids
ever hug at your real or fake beard
everybody tugs at my beard grownups and
I've got to tell you after all these
years it kind of bugs me that everybody
wants to know about the beard but nobody
questions the cookie zone nobody has
ever asked me is the cookie zone real
one glance there lack behaves for sure a
fat guy start out wonder if he's faking
the facial curve and yeah a lot of times
the kids will ask me if I'm a real real
Santa and I'll just go what do you think
and let them pull on my beard and nine
times out of ten if they're on the fence
that pushes them back over the fence to
where they're like oh that is sad
awesome what made you want to be a
professional Santa here's a cute one my
wife was petting an employee committee
for collection food
and at the meeting one of them noted
that a couple of the families had young
kids and it would be so nice if they
could have the Santa I have the package
delivered by Santa and they all laughed
in their budget and then a minute later
one of the women said you know I think I
know where there is an old Christmas
suit in our attic somewhere that nobody
has worn in years but I don't think any
of us could wear it they were all women
and they all had a good laugh about that
but my wife brought the house down when
she said well I know where there's a fat
man with nothing better to do on
Saturday morning so bring the suit in
she did and I got to tell you when she
brought this suit home the next day it
was the cheapest thing I've ever seen
I'm not kidding it's one of those pajama
suits that you get online it tied behind
the neck my wife said how do you feel I
said 10 feet tall bulletproof and I'm
thinking I can fly yep a couple years
later I had spent my kids college fund
on costumes in apparel my brother-in-law
was a professional Santa also so my
sister approached me
she said the money was good the money
was good I stayed in it because it's
really again heartwarming I really enjoy
the touching stories I could shave off
my beard and grow up back before
Christmas again and I don't because I go
all year long as Santa Claus everybody I
know it knows me as Santa so what's on
candy corn it's neither
I love candy corn it's really really
good my problem is now I have dentures
so it's harder to eat the candy corn and
gummy type foods but candy corn is good
it's more of a Halloween candy but it's
good year-round I think like pumpkin
spice shouldn't be a seasonal things
should be year-round
our professional Santa's allowed to be
lactose intolerant well I tell you what
we come from all across the spectrum so
some of us must be I'm not so feel free
to leave milk out for me anytime you
want to
with either of my favorite types of
cookies referred to earlier well
nowadays we thank goodness we have
almond milk and soy milk and every kind
of milk you can think of so yeah it's
okay nowadays it was harder back in the
old day
thank goodness for chocolate chip
cookies and so I'm up what is the least
favorite part of being a professional
Santa seriously the hardest thing about
being a professional Santa is working
with an aging demographic people that
I've been working with for 17 years some
of them were much older when I started
and some of them are no longer with us
when a Santa takes his final sleigh ride
that's my least favorite part of being
Santa probably not being able to be a
professional Santa all year long it's
really really a blast to be Santa
everybody asked me I bet you love seeing
the kids eyes light up and yeah the kids
are great but seeing the parents eyes
light up is even better it's just again
heartwarming I love what I do
favorite part of being a professional
Santa wow that's a list 10 feet tall and
bulletproof pretty much covers it when
you're when you're walking through a
crowd and the people are getting out of
your way and the fur is swishing you've
got these big hand movements going and
traffic is backing up and the
helicopters are overhead that's my
favorite part of being a professional
Santa oh and rides on unusual craft I've
been I've arrived at events in police
cars by train by firetruck obviously a
number of times we were supposed to come
in by blimp one time and the blimp was
grounded the joy the smiles on
everybody's faces it's it's hard to
explain but it's a very very
heartwarming I hate to be repetitive but
it's very rewarding it's a very
rewarding profession I don't even think
of it as a profession it's more they say
if you love what you do you're not
you're not do any job so to be it's not
a job it's a portrayal oh well you guys
ran out of questions long before I ran
out of stories but I see the staff
watching their wrists so I guess I've
been a little long-winded I appreciate
your time thank you for asking all these
questions hopefully I've answered up to
your to the best of my knowledge and to
your satisfaction I thank you guys for
your attention and cooperation in this
very important matter I hope you all
have a great Christmas and ho ho Merry
Christmas
[Music]